there are very few laws in cinema but
there is one thing that you can count on
every successful action movie gets a
sequel that is as consistent as gravity
die hard to die harder so die hard to
once again stars John McClane and he is
in the [ __ ] the [ __ ] this time is that a
terrorist organization is taking control
of the control tower of an airport now
the planes have to circle around until
they get what they want or the planes
lose fuel and just start dropping and
everyone dying and it's up to our man
John McClane to stop it from happening
which sounds like a pretty safe bet but
is it as good as diehard unanimously
everyone says no and I will agree with
them die hard too is pretty much what I
think of when I think of action movies
sequel you look at the sequel and you're
like yeah they made this movie so they
wouldn't have a sequel to die hard I
mean John McClane's running around doing
his John McClane --is-- thing you know
he's taking out baddies that's what we
want to see him do and the stakes are
bigger and everything's bigger it's in
an airport now which is huge it's a pre
9/11 world - you can have cocaine
assault weapons and hookers around your
arm and just it's all carry-on it
doesn't matter but it also is a shining
example showing that bigger isn't always
better
I thought diehard one was so perfect in
what it did in terms of hero and villain
that the villain in die hard - he's good
but he's not Hans Gruber and you don't
expect him to be Hans Gruber but in
terms of what Hans Gruber was which is
the exact opposite in every way possible
- John McClane that this guy in die hard
- is just a villain and he's here to do
what villains do it doesn't really
special behind the guy every movie has
its conveniences and like I said die
hard is the epitome of me watching a
movie going yeah I'll let that
convenience slide I can do that when
there are so many conveniences just
stacked back-to-back I finally just go
do it's too much I'm drawing the line in
the sand right there my friends that
scene when John McClane's in a cockpit
and all the baddies are just lobbing
grenades and they're all right of any
movie that exists in the history of the
world die hard - wins the award for
grenades with longest fuse I swear to
God in the history of cinema before
since after doesn't matter
no grenade from Penn pulled - explosion
has ever taken this long watch the scene
it's absurd
this next convenience it's a bit of a
spoiler so I'm gonna say spoiler when
this goes away unplug your ears there's
this group that pretty much it's all
[ __ ] they're like oh we're bad guys
but we're posing as good guys in which
case the actual bad guys and them who
are also bad guys but you don't know it
yet put blanks into their machine guns
in the movie and they start shooting at
each other for a dog and pony show to
fool everybody
but who is everybody I mean everybody
really consists of John McClane and a
couple other people so who is this
everybody that they have to put the show
on for the answer is you the audience
it's one of those things where they're
like oh we want to twist in the movie
and these guys are actually going to be
bad guys but we don't know how to make
it flow into the movie but luckily hey
we don't need it to flow it's a die hard
sequel people are going to watch it they
might as well just do the Zack Morris
Marty kaan Deadpool thing just turn to
the screen and be like hi audience how
you doing we know about you apparently
because we're putting all this on for
you if they really had to fool John
McClane and a couple other people when
they're out in the middle of nowhere at
the church which is what happens you
have the drop on them they don't know
you're bad guys just go up behind him
shoot him in the head be like okay no
need for blanks solve that problem
immediately things like this make me
overanalyze the movie and just take me
out of myself and I feel like a critic
and I hate that [ __ ] not one it's a die
hard movie because I then I start
feeling bad because I want to like it
because it's nostalgic I remember don't
die hard movies awesome everyone likes
die hard movies right now it's not to
say die hard to is terrible because like
I said it's a popcorn flick action movie
and it's not supposed to you know be
mamma Deus but I would like a movie to
actually make sense and flow and when it
does it is just agitating so at this
point in the review I have to rate the
movie so do I make the call and go yeah
it's a good time no alcohol required
because it's a nostalgic movie and it's
a popcorn flick not meant to be taken
seriously or do I actually rate the
movie in terms of it being a movie in
which case it's not as good as you want
it to be then I realize whatever I do
rate it the rating is just one sentence
long it doesn't change the rest of the
review it's all the same which is why I
have phrase ratings because I rate the
movie how I see the movie and in the
reality of the situation if I'm being
honest die hard to die harder is a lot
of fun if you're drunk
ya know it's a party because
drunk or sober hans gruber did say that
best in Fekkai a manufacture it's the
perfect
ambient noise movie you know if you need
a movie to be on just because you need
ambient noise when you work out or play
a video game or something
die hard - die hard fun movie in that
respect fun movie in that regard but in
terms of the die hard movies it is the
bottom one alright so in terms of sequel
what is your least favorite sequel in
terms of all suite movies sequel
whatever it may be
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more